hi there are you interested in
winning the lottery then let me tell you
this video
is not for you this video is not about
winning the lottery okay i've done
enough videos with lottery in the title
only for people to be mad at me for not
telling them how to win the lottery
this is about computer science research
and very unfortunately the author of
this paper has decided to put this word
in the title so if you're here
because you want to win the lottery this
is not for you
it's something completely different for
everyone else
today we're looking at the hardware
lottery by sarah hooker
of google brain this paper
is it's kind of a mix it's part
a of a historic look back at hardware
and software developments in machine
learning
and it is a analysis of kind of the
current situation
and an outlook and sort of an opinion
piece of the way forward and how
hardware and software should mix and
what we should focus on in the future
so the basic the basic principle
is quite simple in this paper
it introduces this term the hardware
lottery
this essay introduces the term hardware
to describe when a research idea wins
because it is compatible
with available software and hardware and
not because
the idea is superior to alternative
research
directions okay so right off the bat
um i think this is a statement
where i think many people can agree or
i think almost everyone will some agree
with this statement
in to to a certain degree but certainly
to a high
degree right we are all aware that of
course
we have the hardware we have hardware is
very inflexible it's expensive to
develop
and so on so any sort of software
development any algorithmic development
may simply succeed because it is suited
to the hardware
that we have so that was my
first reaction when i read this paper
it's a it's a
it's a very gut feeling of yes of course
this is the case
but then the historic analysis is also
nice but i was wondering
what is there a deeper reason to to kind
of go into this
and we are going to see some pros and
cons
uh that i think in this paper right here
where it i'm not exactly entirely sure
what specific point it's trying to make
the the overarching point i completely
agree with
uh the fact that of course what hardware
is here is important and
may lead to certain ideas succeeding but
it i have i have trouble with the the
narrower points and i'm gonna try to
illustrate this in this paper
while also telling you what the paper
says so
first of all um here the term is called
the hardware lottery but off the bat you
already see that it says a research idea
wins because it is compatible with
available software and hardware
so the hardware lottery right off the
bat
is connect is means
that also the software is there
so it's technically the hard end
software lottery
and the bigger the bigger question
i would have to someone arguing that
really the hardware lottery is an
important concept to have is
why what does what distinguishes the
hardware lottery let's let's even say
it's just hardware
what distinguishes the hardware lottery
from any
lottery like why can't i say okay
there's the x lottery
and the x lottery is as
any circumstance any circumstance
that that surrounds a research idea
right here you have idea one
idea two idea three and they all depend
on many circumstances and
x is one of those circumstances and it
just so happens that the circumstance in
the world
favors idea two and a different
circumstance would actually favor
idea one what's so special about
hardware other than it's more expensive
than software
right to to um to illustrate this
further let's say okay you have you have
hardware and you say well hardware is
expensive but then again
um you can sort of build a hierarchy
where
okay down here there is like ideas
they depend on software like software
frameworks that we have such as
tensorflow pytorch
these again depend on particular
hardware
but and you can say okay the hardware is
much more expensive so we
we we are not as flexible and the ideas
might just succeed because of the
hardware but then
you can go even step further and say
well
up here is sort of the consumer
um if you don't like the market term
then maybe say the society the end user
and so on
because the hardware ultimately is
directed towards
what humans in society need and
that changes over time as well so and
and
it's it's way more expensive to change
the needs of human society
than to change the hardware so i can
just also
claim okay x is now society so
the one particular research idea down
here
might win simply because it is more
suited to the current societal needs
and that kind of carries over and you
you might say well
make doesn't that make it a good idea
doesn't that make it preferable to
idea idea 2 preferable to idea 3 over
here that would just
optimize for a different society which
leads us to the question
what does it mean to first what does it
mean to
win here it just says a research idea
wins
and you might have an idea so i have an
idea it's not clearly defined here but
maybe winning means that a lot of
researchers
actually research in that direction
and the other question is
here and not because the idea is
superior to alternative research
directions
and here my question would be what does
superior mean
what what does it what does it mean for
an idea to be superior
as i said here certainly if an idea is
more incongruent
with current societal needs you might
claim it's
superior and someone else might say well
if societal needs were different then a
different research idea
might be suited better the same way
someone could say well if hardware was
different then a different research idea
might be better maybe you can say if
hardware was different a different
research idea might be better suited to
the current needs of society but then
i'm pretty sure i can go two three four
levels up here
um again so
these these terms are a bit vague i
think we can all
the again the initial the initial
sentiment when reading this is
absolutely
in favor right i absolutely agree i
don't want to want to trash this i just
want to
sort of um i try to
think a bit deeper about what is
actually said here and
this is where sort of my my troubles
start
so let's dig a bit into the historic
part
and i think the point the paper
is sort of trying to make is that um
not yet that there are specific
hardware choices that were made at one
particular point
and because it's so expensive to change
hardware
um that means that a lot of researchers
simply go along with whatever ideas work
on that particular hardware that's
available and
other research ideas are neglected
simply because the hardware
isn't available which again this is a
sentiment that i think we can we can all
agree
with so the the first part here the
paper is
is in the in the following sections and
this is a bit important to keep in mind
as a
red thread because i i feel
one can get lost in the details of the
paper
so in the first section section two we
ask what
has incentivized the development of
software hardware and
machine learning research in isolation
um oh we need to read this first this
essay
begins by acknowledging a crucial
paradox machine learning researchers
mostly ignore hardware despite the role
it plays in determining
what ideas succeed so the argument is
that
we we develop ideas independent of
hardware
but also we don't
it kind of makes it a double double
point it says that
we think we just think about ideas but
the ideas we might think about
may be shaped by the hardware that's
available
and if we're not aware of that we might
not
we might not see other ideas as viable
so section two asks what has
incentivized the development of software
hardware and machine learning research
in isolation so
where does this come from that we don't
think about the hardware
that's at the end um section three
considers the
ramifications of this siloed evaluation
with examples of
early hardware and software lotteries so
this is the kind of risk
historical look back then
today the hardware landscape is
increasingly heterogeneous
this essay posits that the hardware
lottery has
not gone away and the gap between the
winners and the losers will grow
increasingly larger so this is
a point that the paper basically makes
that
um this hardware lottery has not gone
away so
right now we are in this hardware
lottery and it does so specifically with
regards to
saying that chips like gpus and tpus and
even more specialized chips are
optimized to neural networks
and that's why the whole world sort of
over focuses on neural networks right
now and discards other research ideas
and the gap between the winners and the
losers
will grow increasingly larger meaning
that the research ideas that are seen as
inviable now
if we develop even more hardware into
that direct
into the direction of neural networks
those research ideas will become
more and more inaccessible to the
community
then lastly sections four to five unpack
these arguments
so the ones that we've just seen section
six concludes with some thoughts on what
it will take to avoid future
hardware lotteries all right so
section two here is this sort of
historic
look back and it goes from these
um it it the point is here separate
tribes
so the point is that something has
made it such that the communities the
software communities and the hardware
communities
and the idea let's say the idea
communities the researchers in
ai algorithms let's call them the
algorithmers
they they don't think that much about
each other
and it makes the case that early
machines were super duper specialized
um early machines were single use were
not expected to be repurposed for new
tasks because
of the cost of electronics and the lack
of cross-purpose software so early
machines early computing machines were
just
single purpose and so on but that all
changed when the whole world focused on
sort of general purpose
cpus that could execute any instructions
of course according to
touring machine or of von neumann
architectures
so the point that the paper makes is at
some point a shift
happened the general purpose computer
area crystallized in 1969
when an opinion piece by young engineer
called gordon moore
appeared in electronics magazine with
the app title cramming more components
onto
circuit boards that's a cool title
so this famously gave rise to moore's
law
or predicted you could double the amount
of transistors on an integrated circuit
every two
years and this
sort of held true um where
people stopped building general like
sorry
people stopped building special purpose
hardware
but invested just more and more and more
into building these general purpose
chips these
cpus um that
and the reason why they stopped
making specialized hardware is any
specialized hardware
you build will simply be surpassed
uh by the next generation of cpus so
even if you make a
specific purpose hardware for some
problem you just have to wait
like one or two of these cycles and
ordinary general purpose cpus will
simply have will will overtake your
specialized
hardware and since cpus are general
purpose
the market for them is naturally huge
so this this has made it such that
what was mainly developed was general
purpose
cpus i i think the paper wants to make
the point though i'm not in
exactly sure i think it wants to make
the point that even though the cpus
might
be called general purpose they
aren't general purpose like they have
their specific advantages
and disadvantages and that's going to
hurt for example
neural networks in the years following
this
so in conclusion to this chapter they
say in the absence of
any lever with which to influence
hardware development machine learning
researchers
rationally began to treat hardware as a
sunk cost to work around
rather than something fluid that could
be shaped
however just because we have abstracted
away hardware does not mean it has
ceased to exist early computer science
history tells us
there are many hardware lotteries where
the choice of hardware and software has
determined which ideas succeeded
and which fail and the example is
kind of the charles babbage's
analytic engine that charles babbage
designed
but was something like 50 years
earlier or so then
parts could even be manufactured for
this idea
to succeed and we know many stories of
these
people being ahead of their time and
they have this interesting quote i think
somewhere from silicon valley here being
too early
is the same as being wrong
and this paper of course focuses on
hardware
but to come back the conclusion of this
chapter
is that because
uh of this general purpose area because
the entire focus was on building general
purpose cpus
this has led to people not really having
integrated
thought of hardware software algorithm
but
treating hardware as this thing that can
execute any instruction
and then the the algorithm comes on top
of this sort of black box that we can't
really change
we we just have the hardware we have um
yeah which which comes back i'm and
again i'm not sure
like sure they did sure i agree
that the entire world focusing on
general purpose comp
cpus has some influence but
certainly hardware is just expensive to
make so you could argue that even if
this hadn't
happened a machine learning researcher
wouldn't necessarily
think about the hardware but they would
at least have a choice
if there were a selection of hardwares
right
okay so that was the section two
section three now we really go into the
historic
evidences and there are kind of early
historic evidence
like this uh charles babbage's machine
that
he invented um an early example the
analytical machine in 1837
um and no it wasn't even decade it was
only surfaced during world war ii in the
first part of the 20th
century electronic vacuum tubes were
heavily used
uh were heavily used for heavily used
this is
i i've not i've noticed a number of of
typos in
in the paper i i realize it's a preprint
if the author
is listening um i can also i can also
make a list but this this one just
popped out
uh for radio communication and radar
during world war ii these vacuum tubes
were repurposed to provide
the compute power necessary to break the
german enigma code
so it would be long after not only after
charles babbage invented this machine
but
even after he died that people
would would sort of re-take and
in some parts reinvent his ideas
to to build modern computers
the big example though that the paper
makes is
what it calls the lost decades and
this is the story of neural networks
coupled with two things with an ai
winter
and uh a focus on expert systems and
maybe also though that's not entirely
mentioned here a focus on things like
svms so
i think it's widely known that the main
ingredients for neural networks
are very very very old so here the paper
gives some examples
back propagation invented in 63
reinvented reinvented again
and deep convolutional networks
paired with back propagation by and la
con
it says however it was only three
decades later
that deep neural networks were widely
accepted as a promising research
direction
i think this this sort of the timeline
here is
this here probably refers to around 2010
um shortly after that of course
alexnet beats imagenet and so on but
even earlier
a bit earlier people were doing heavy
research into neural networks
and three decades later so
this is paired with kind of these
numbers right here
let's say 1970 1980 when
these ideas were invented presented
but computers back then were simply
unsuited to the to run neural networks
here it says um
the gap between these algorithmic
advances and empirical success is in
large part two to
incompatible hardware during the general
purpose computing areas
hardware like cpus were heavily favored
and widely available
cpus were good at executing any set of
complex instructions but occur
high memory costs because of the need to
cache intermediate results
and process one instruction at a time
this is known as the von neumann
bottleneck the available compute is
restricted by the
lone channel between cpu and memory
along which date has to travel
sequentially
so the paper goes on and says
um there were some efforts into
specialized hardware for neural networks
but funding was kind of not there
and other specialized hardware was more
into the direction
of popular ideas than like
prologue and lisp which could do expert
systems
and not necessarily neural networks
and only only it would take
a hardware fluke in the early 2000s a
full
four decades after the first paper about
backpack
back propagation was published for the
insight about massive parallelism to be
operationalized in a useful way
for connectionist deep neural networks
a graphical processing unit was
originally introduced in the 1970s as a
specialized accelerator for video games
and developing graphics
yada yada gpus were repurposed for an
entirely
unimagined use case to train deep neural
networks
had one critical advantage over cpus
they were far better at parallelizing a
set of simple
decomposable instructions such as matrix
multiplications
multiples multiplications
um multiples
i don't know so
the the point here is that the ideas
were around for a long time
but it would take gpus to
make them work and
so the the image that the paper builds
up
i think is that you have these
you're you're here and you research
and then you have a decision to make
which hardware do i build for the future
and there are two directions this is
direction one and this is direction two
and let's say for whatever reason
direction one is chosen
okay then because it's so expensive
to build different hardware the
the world largely goes with direction
one
and builds on top of that okay so
that also means that all the research
ideas
uh that profit from direction one
will appear to be much more effective
that research ideas that would have
profited from
direction two and it sort of says that
neural networks
are over here and it's sort of
the and the the let's say the other
systems what do we give
expert systems let's call them expert
systems
and other types of ideas were over here
and they appeared to work really well
until um
they stopped in progress and then by
accident
sort of this road here was traveled
use with gpus so it was not obvious but
by accident
still this was developed and then neural
networks could flourish
and if it wasn't for that fluke if it
wasn't for video games basically or
animation
we would have never known that neural
networks
work as well as they do so
again that's the point the paper makes
and i think we can all
agree uh with that particular point
but i want to again i want to build up
sort of a different picture right here
in that
um why why
is only like i feel hardware is
considered a bit much here so
i think you can make the general case
that at any junction you have
several things you can choose and then
once you choose a thing
all the things go in that direction like
new ideas will
be more in that direction also new
hardware will be more in that direction
because
a lot of people research on it the paper
also makes the point there is kind of
this feedback loop
but let's say neural networks were down
here
what i would i would argue and this is
a bit of a point that paper makes in
in a half half formulated way i think is
that
it basically says that
had we had we invested
in matrix multipliers in gpus
instead of cpus in these early years
that means that neural networks would
have sort of
succeeded as an idea at that time
and i'm not entirely convinced of this
because first of all you can see right
here gpus were actually around
in the 1970s so the hardware
was was available it's not it's not like
it was super easy in in 2010
it was for these early researchers to
build their code into gpu compatible
code that was certainly hard especially
if you read the papers but
it would have been hard in 1970 as well
it would not have been significantly
harder i think so i
i'm not sure if the picture is really
like this or if the picture
so if this is the cpu direction is more
like that neural networks are actually
somewhere up here and the fact is
we we we actually needed the good cpus
in order to develop the in order to make
use of the gpus
right and this here would be gpu
um in order to make use of the gpus to
then enable
these neural networks on the gpus
because certainly
it has it has helped a lot that cpus
were built
that um you know computers
just built on gpus would be sad
computers computers built on cpus are
cool they can do multi-processing
they can do internet they can do
actually they can do most of the video
game except display the graphics
and very arguably that without
the heavy focus on cpus we would not
have
neural networks today even if we had
invested
all of that effort into building gpus
because society has just advanced so
much because of cpu so
i'm i'm sort of tempted to challenge
this notion
here that uh just because of the
the happenstance that cpus were advanced
at that time
that neural networks are didn't have
their breakthrough back then i think we
needed both
um that being said i do agree with the
paper that
we might have never ever realized that
neural networks
worked if it weren't for the fact that
there is
specialized hardware around um
yeah so so that would be my my
points to this the paper
makes yeah makes this point about okay
there is hardware lotteries and in
so now it also introduces software
lotteries though
it said at the beginning that hardware
lotteries included software but i'm
going to
guess that the general concept of a
lottery
was simply presented and again i
i don't see exactly what's so special
about hardware because again i can make
the same case for software
it's just a shorter time frame i can
make the same case for theory
right like whatever now neural tangent
kernels are
are are the hit right everyone's like
wow ntks
who knows right but some big names
announced this and some theory has been
done in this direction
and because there is already a big
momentum lots of people
publish in it who knows if that's if
that's a good idea or if there were
other ideas that
had we done the fundamental work in this
uh would flourish right now
i again i don't i agree with the
sentiment i don't see why
the hardware is the why the hardware is
uh
is such a special case right here
so the next thing that the paper looks
like is kind of the current
day so it tries to make the point
that we might be in a hardware lottery
right now and again the the intuition of
course is yes of course
we have the hardware we have it's
difficult to change
especially since hardware builds up on
hardware with the tree i drew before
let's draw it again you draw a tree
and literally every decision you make in
the tree and this doesn't only need to
be hardware
right every single decision you make
will mean that pretty much
all of the previous choices here are
now fixed and ingrained we build upon
we build upon inventions of the past
it's impossible to go back and
do all of these things again and if you
see something curious right here and
this is where we're going to
later i want you to see what happens
if here here is a good idea like here is
my super duper booper idea
and my super duper booper idea simply
didn't make the cut
for that choice like someone chose a
different hardware direction software
direction software library direction
what not it wasn't in vogue and my idea
was
unpopular then if one choice is made
this choice right here it's it's hard to
go back if two choices are made
right that build upon each other it's
even harder to go back
so as time goes on it's harder and
harder and harder to go back
which is a point that the paper will
make at the end that
the difference between the winners and
the losers is getting bigger and bigger
which is an effect that this idea that
once was
a curiosity that could be investigated
becomes
a very costly investigation because we
need to reinvent and re-engineer a whole
bunch of
decisions and if at with time goes on
it's simply forgotten because there's
so much that we have built past this
um however
this is for the loser right this is the
loser however for the winner
i i i disagree right here because
here it says okay this direction the
idea direction here
let's say there is a super cool idea
that would beat neural the crap out of
neural networks
um what not whatever whatever the latest
schmidt hooper paper is
uh that that idea would be neural
networks and this here
is neural networks and everyone's doing
neural networks
and schmidt uber's idea is just
forgotten about now
to say that neural networks are the
winner and the winners
will increase and increase and increase
is correct but it forgets that
right here there is this whole branching
so within the neural networks
you have again this branching and maybe
over here what kind of neural networks
were completely forgotten
like mlps no mlps are maybe still a
thing
um i don't even remember like early
early neural networks where 10
h non-linearities for mlps or something
like this
nine by nine filters nine by nine
filters in convolution
things like this right uh we
it's sort of the nine by nine filters
are technically in the class of neural
networks
but as time progresses and this branch
here are the three by three filters
which are massively out competing the
nine by nine filters
so the nine by nine filters are
forgotten
and it could be that if the 9x9 filters
no sorry because of the 3x3 filters now
we have specialized hardware that is
exclusively focuses on 3x3 filters so we
go down this route down this route down
this route that understood
and there might have been some other
super duper idea
down here that only works when we have
really big filters
and now we never know that this existed
right um so to say that the difference
between the winners and the losers gets
bigger and bigger
sort of misjudges that these winners
will be fractionated and fractionated
and fractionated
and every push in one direction comes
with costs to these other directions
within that winner branch
but this is i don't yeah ultimately
you know you have a choice you have a
choice do i want to go back
and go this direction or do i want to
add something here it might
just might be worth more for society to
go up here
the paper is going to argue at the end
that we should sort of
keep funding uh alternative directions
in hardware which
i i think is always a good thing to to
not
lock in on particular ideas but also
uh you can you sort of have a have to
strike a balance
because you know researching on things
that already work and make them better
is a crucial part as well because you
can discard these
sub ideas that don't make any sense all
right
so it gives some examples of current
hardware
lottery winners um to improve efficiency
there is a shift from task agnostic
hardware like cpus
to domain specialized hardware that
tailor the design
to make certain tasks more efficient the
first examples of domain-specific
hardware released over the last few
years
tpus and then it also says edge tpus
cortec arm cortex m55 facebook's bixer
which
i think is just like a box with eight
gpus in it and some infiniband
um optimize explicitly for costly
operations common to deep neural
networks like matrix multiplies
so here i have again
there's this double meaning so it says
here is task agnostic hardware like cpus
but at the same time
it argues that cpus are particularly bad
at
matrix matrix multiplies so it's not
really
task agnostic it's just focused on on
different tasks but
i see what the what the paper means
right here we do
build hardware that make matrix
multiplies faster
which means that neural networks that
benefits
neural networks research
closer collaboration between hardware
and research communities will
undoubtedly continue to make the
training
and deployment of deep neural networks
more efficient
for example unstructured pruning and
weight quantization
are very successful compression
techniques in the network but inc
are incompatible with current hardware
and compilations
and compilations kernels hardware and
compilations kernels um
i don't know what that means but it's
incompatible with current hardware the
paper
argues that because we see that these
ideas
are good there will be specialized
hardware
for them and i think the point the paper
is trying to make
is sort of like see another win for
neural networks because we go down the
neural network road
people focus on neural networks focus on
how to prune them and so on hardware
will be developed which will lock us in
further into neural networks
which again is paper is basically saying
like look because we went this road
right here
we're gonna go this road a lot more
but then what you have to see is that if
we in
if we then from this road go here
because we do want to do
weight quantization in this particular
way we
also are going to neglect this which
would be
doing some whatever other thing that we
could do
um yeah so
there's always there's always in each
decision there's a branching
undoubtedly the paper is correct and it
says the branching decides the future
but
i think the focus here on hardware and
neural networks versus non-neural
networks
is a bit it's very specific to that
thing it then it makes the
it makes the point why it matters so why
it matters
it matters because the paper says
okay um where is that
here in 2019 a paper was published
called machine learning is stuck in a
rut the authors consider the difficulty
of training
a new type of computer vision
architecture called capsule networks
and i kind of realized that capsule
networks aren't really
suited to current um to current
to current hardware and he says
whether or not you agree that capsule
networks are the future of computer
vision
the authors say something interesting
about the difficulty of trying to train
a new type of image classification
architecture on domain specific
specialized hardware hardware design has
prioritized delivering on commercial use
cases
while built-in flexibility to
accommodate the next generation of
research ideas remains a distant
secondary consideration which is true
though i would also say i mean gpu
cpus and gpus combined are extremely
general operations like they're
they're very very generalized okay gpus
are good at matrix multiplies
but cpus are good at a lot of other
things so i would say the gpu cpu combo
is a very very very
flexible general purpose hardware design
that doesn't
doesn't lock you in too much and maybe
maybe
it's just that capsule networks are by
algorithmic design
way way harder to implement like to
build
specialized hardware for capsule
networks i'm not sure
if that would even be possible and to
speed them up to the degree
that cnns are sped up by gpus
just out of the algorithmic nature of
capsule networks and i've done videos on
capsule networks they sound pretty cool
but
they also sound like implementing the
thing
in hardware is going to be quite
tough even if you build specialized
hardware
they also go into gpt three
claiming that um
so current the paper claims that because
we are kind of locked in in this neural
network
uh this neural network paradigm in this
kind of hardware
several major research labs are making
this bet engaging in a bigger
is better race in the number of model
parameters and collecting ever more
expansive data sets
however it is unclear whether this is
sustainable
an algorithm's scalability is often
thought of as the performance gradient
relative to the available
resources given more resources how does
the performance
increase and they go into examples here
that
you can scale up the parameters which
gives you
less and less of a of a gain so it's
like
this diminishing return over time
which it brings up gpt3 which i find
interesting because gpt3
showed in a way okay it was in log space
but it showed a
fairly fairly linear decrease in
perplexity so a long linear decreasing
perplexity given more parameters
which goes a bit against the narrative
of the paper and also
in terms of this definition up here
given more resources how does the
performance increase i see
the fact that you say well it's 12
billion sorry 12 million dollars
to train gpt3 says right here
12 million dollars to train gpt3 on the
other hand i would say
what's the cost of you know building
specialized hardware to research
alternative research directions by the
way we have no idea what alternative
research directions work
so the only thing we could do is fund
all hardware
and if we had to fund all hardware for
other algorithms then select the ones
that are promising then
invest more and so on 12 million dollars
will get us nowhere
which i think is a point the paper is
trying to make
but from a efficiency perspective
given where we are now it's it's
actually
more viable to build gpt free which
again i think this is something the
paper agrees with but
um at the same time it tries to make the
point that
look we are investing more and more and
more and we're getting less and less out
of it maybe
it's time to go a different route in
terms of in terms of hardware
but that's going to be more and more
expensive the more
we go into this neural network direction
i'm not yeah i'm not sure about this
again
if you think of this tree um
the paper basically tries to argue that
what gpt-3 is trying to do is it's
trying to
make a push up here into the next kind
of
push the frontier on the path that we
have gone
uh for a while and the paper is trying
to say that
had we gone had we imaginarily gone a
different path down here
a equally hard push in this direct in a
direction would maybe yield a better
result
yes maybe but
yeah um but the question is is it
at what point does it become viable to
sort of
abandon this entire direction and skip
and kind of start there because we would
need to do the whole tree thing again
and then
within the tree the same
logic applies it does though
make a good comparison to the human
brain which works
fundamentally different it says um
while deep neural networks may be
scalable it may be prohibitively
expensive to do so in a regime of
comparable intelligence to
humans uh an apt metaphor is that we
appear to be trying to build a ladder to
the moon
sort of saying that we can't we we can't
the way at the rate where we scale
neural networks right now
um it's not conceivable that we reach
human level intelligence by simply
scaling them up which
is why we might want to investigate
different
entirely different directions and why we
might want to
investigate entirely different hardware
choices
um yeah
which you know granted um
that's correct though i would say
transformers aren't
particularly suited to the hardware
because they require such huge memories
and gpus
traditionally have been rather limited
in memories
uh in memory sorry and and transformers
still
kick ass on these on this hardware even
though
memory is extremely limited compared to
like
cpu memory and only now do we see
gpu manufacturers focus on on
more memory so you can argue from the
perspective of the paper and say c
because we have neural network hardware
now people are building more neural
network hardware but also you can say
that
initially a bad choice was made sort of
but researchers still managed to
demonstrate
transformers would work and now the
hardware
is developing in this direction
which is also i think the paper argues
at some point again i i
i have a i have a hard point parsing out
a a a direct point here i think
the paper is more meant to make you
sort of think about
think about the different points it
brings up
which is also probably why this video is
more of me rambling than anything else
so here it says that currently
there are some initiatives to build
other types
of chips other types of hardware and so
on but they
as well as the last ones they might be
not enough because
it takes producing a next generation
chip typically costs
30 to 80 million dollars and two to
three years to develop and
even that is however even investment of
this magnitude may still be woefully
inadequate as hardware
based on new materials requires long
lead times of 10 to 20 years
in public investment and is currently
far below
industry levels of r d um
this this is the kind of darpa
and china who funded research in this
direction
so the paper says it might be way too
little
though it also says there are a couple
of good uh
lights at the end of the tunnel saying
experiments using reinforcement
learning to optimize chip placement may
help decrease
cost i think i've done a video on this
paper
there are also renewed interest in
reconfigurable hardware such as
field program gate arrays and course
grain reconfigure
configurable arrays so this is hardware
that you can
sort of meta program so you can take the
hardware and you can
specialize it by programming it
and so it's kind of meta programming it
you can sort of take one of these things
and make it into like a sort of a gpu
if you need it like that and then you
can reprogram it
program it differently for a different
application
though if again if i take the other side
of this paper i would say
well isn't that the same thing that cpus
were
and yet still cpus made it
almost impossible for neural networks to
run aren't you
even though fpgas are
very general aren't you making implicit
choices on
the ideas that are very well suited to
fpgas or the ideas that are very well
suited to using reinforcement learning
to optimize
chip placement isn't isn't that the
exact same
thing um yeah again i guess you can make
this argument
at in like at infinitum
infinitum infinum no infinum is
different
okay this this video must come must come
to an end
so the last part here says that uh what
is also needed is kind of a software
revolution
that there is a shorter feedback time
where it imagines software
that tells researchers
which hardware their algorithm is
particularly suited or
how their algorithm would fare on
different hardware
such that if you invent a new algorithm
it doesn't work on a gpu you could sort
of
submit it to the software and then the
software would tell you well that this
would
work really well if type x of hardware
existed and then you can
maybe invest money into into that rather
than discarding
your idea
in conclusion yeah it doesn't the
conclusion isn't very long
the performance of an algorithm is
fundamentally intertwined with the
hardware and software it runs on
this essay proposes the term hardware
lottery to describe
how these downstream choices determine
whether a research idea succeeds or
fails
today the hardware landscape is
increasingly heterogeneous
this essay posits that the hardware
lottery has not gone away
and the gap between the winners and
losers will grow
increasingly larger in order to avoid
future hardware lotteries we need to
make it easier to quantify the
opportunity cost
of settling for the hardware and
software
we have and my conclusion is i
generally agree with this paper i really
appreciate the the historic overview
um but i do think the focus is
it it centers too much around hardware
where i think this lottery case you can
make for
literally any single branching choice
and maybe you weigh that by the cost
that
it takes to revert or change that choice
in the future
and it also focuses a lot
on neural networks versus non-neural
networks where
it kind of yeah this this winners and
losers thing
uh where it says neural networks are the
winners and
if we investigate more into neural
networks then they will
remain the winners because of this
feedback loop however
it's kind of in my opinion discards the
thing that within the neural networks in
the next
choice of hardware they're going to be
winners and losers again
and again and again and they're going to
be entire branches of neural network
research that are abandoned because they
don't fit the hardware choices
uh once more and this gap between
what it's conceived the winners and the
losers it only it compares
losers in terms of an idea that was had
uh in one year to the winners which are
always reevaluated every year so
um it's kind of not a fair comparison in
my opinion
and then also um
no that was it for me yes i i do
i do implore you if you are interested
in things like this as i said this is
more of historical and opinion
peace trying to make some argument and
give you some
directions to think about which is is
pretty cool as a
change to a simple bland research paper
all right that was it from me again if
you're still here waiting for how to win
the lottery
this is not the video bye bye see you
next time